I only met Kobe one time and and it was
after he won an Oscar and I had to say
look respect to you but I I got I gotta
give you some grief because you're
making you make it look a little too
easy my friend
rookie I got to treat you like the
rookie who got off to a great start
gracious man so intelligent so
interested and therefore you know such
such such a loss and you know and it
just it just a horrible brutal reminder
that we have to all appreciate every day
because you know what you want you just
you just never know none of us are
immune and that's the fragile nature of
life and somehow we have to take that
that tragedy and and use it as for
something you know he would want that
some kind of some sort of fuel to be
able to be the best person you can be
while you're while you're here Ron
Howard reminiscing on meeting the late
great Kobe Bryant at the TV Academy Hall
of Fame ceremony in Los Angeles that's
pretty remarkable and you know and it's
and it's a it's a great night it's a
great honor and it's great too it's I've
reached a point in my life right I know
everybody who's you know who's being
honored and so it's a it's a great
feeling you know I mean they do a good
job of acknowledging all facets of the
of the medium from you know from
executives to directors and you know
actors and it's just a you know
fantastic array this year when you first
on your when you first got inducted well
the great thing is you you know it's
it's not like an it's not like an award
show you you you know so you can you can
really prepare for it and I you know
it's just it's a great it's a great
memory it's not it's not there's not a
lot of pressure it's very it's warm you
know but TV is TV as an industry is like
that you know everybody there's
something so dynamic and and and the
work ethic is pretty intense and so you
know
veteran TV people are pretty pretty cool
customers and pretty relaxed yeah oh
we're off to a good start
Roberto benebabes a great showrunner
terrific young cast and you know and and
they're they're just getting started I
mean they're really finding their
characters as they go along and so you
know I'm really appreciative that the
numbers are off to such a great start
you just always hope for that and you
never you never quite know you know what
the reactions gonna be
you put your best foot forward but you
know again we got fantastic director a
great showrunner great cast and and it's
it's from adapted from an Israeli show
and that has a similar tone and a
similar feel so that that gave gave
everyone a kind of a guideposts
[Music]